the lions at number 27 on our preseason
power rankings
and look last year they gave us some
reason to believe early on chris that it
was changing they won some games that
maybe in the past they would have lost
and then they lost matthew stafford and
it all fell apart and near the end of
the year martha firestone ford made it
clear that matt patricia would be back
as the coach bob quinn would be back as
the gm but she also made it clear that
there are expectations for 2020. and i i
thought maybe she was a little too
candid because i think the message was
hey folks if you complain loudly enough
we'll fire these guys next year but you
know they got to come out and they got
to get it done this is the year this has
been a franchise that's been in
perpetual rebuild mode they they get to
the playoffs from time to time they
haven't won a playoff game since 1991.
they've got 11 years with matthew
stafford and not a postseason victory to
show for it and i feel like this is the
year for the coaching staff for the
front office and maybe for stafford
himself yeah i agree i agree it's year
three you know it's year three for matt
patricia bob quinn that combination
there i know bob quinn's been there a
little bit longer than that we've talked
about a lot you know it's not easy just
to implement new england in one year or
even two years you know new england is a
well thought out
unbelievable scheme as far as
connecting the front office to the
coaches and everybody everybody in the
organization being on the same page and
scouting pro personnel whatever it may
be so that's not easy to implement into
an organization that you know as you
said has kind of had lost its way for a
long long time now you know year one of
the patricia uh patricia you know era
there was an adjustment of the culture i
mean we saw matthew stafford struggled
in 2018 it was one of the years of his
whole career where i went damn he's off
what's going on here you know then he
got a little hurt 2019 i felt like ooh
the lion's showing some promise here and
matt stafford played unbelievable
football i mean he really did he played
top five quality football he got hurt
and of course that hurt the team and
then what also hurt the team is they did
not have a proper backup quarterback and
their team fell apart and that made
their record look a whole lot worse so
they need stafford to stay healthy for
one we know that but this is a team
that's intriguing to me they are you
know the offense i think has enough
studs mike i don't know how you feel or
look at it but i go oh it kind of
excites me when you start to go through
each position defense
i think they've given themselves a
chance this year i don't think it can be
dominant but between free agency and the
draft i think they've done enough to
certainly be a better defense and better
than what they were last year which was
pretty damn bad
well the challenge for the team has been
the transition
to the patriot way right and the
resistance that that has
happened internally darius slay one of
the prime examples of it he did not
react kindly to matt patricia's ways
matt patricia even though they say
they're not going to be like bill
belichick they've been around bill
belichick for 15 years they don't
realize how much they're like bill
belichick just by osmosis right they're
like bill belichick
darius slay didn't like that so as you
clear out guys guys like him and damon
harrison they really didn't want to be
part of that solution and you hope you
can bring in guys who want to be part of
it they're getting more and more guys
with that patriot dna in there um that
and and the question is is this the year
that it finally clicks and you're right
on the offensive side of the ball i mean
they they've got some guys who are
intriguing we we know that kenny
galladay and marvin jones jr are great
receivers
and with the and with deandre swift you
know they've been searching for barry
sanders
for 21 years now
and and they've never found another
running back they traded up to get job
at best they thought he was going to be
the answer in 2010 and the concussion
issue knocked him out of the career for
or out of the league for good in 2011.
they just have constantly been been
struggling to get the running game that
they need to complement the passing game
and maybe with deandre swift uh they and
carry on johnson who has shown real
potential so far in his career they can
maybe come up with a one-two punch that
gives them the balance that they need
offensively that will give them the
balance they need as a team
and and you know if the defense improves
the i feel like that vibe has been
around the line i know every year last
40 years you're right hey maybe maybe
it'll all work and then every year it
doesn't work no i mean you know it's
it's it's always by a shoelace it seems
like even the years they went to the
playoffs you're kind of just like whoa
whoa whoa okay it's working out you know
i'm not sure why or how because it
doesn't seem like they have any dominant
part of their football team but they've
kind of made it happen
you know and and you know i guess when
you look at the offensive side of the
football you know i know matt patricia
is a defensive coach certainly and he's
always going to play through them to a
degree but i think he's got to be
careful about that i don't know if his
defense is talented enough to play that
way always you know it's the worst past
defense in football last year they
certainly did some things to help out
their secondary duron harmon's there you
know desmond trafant from the atlanta
falcons jeff akuda in the first round
you know some other pieces there left
over so hopefully they can be more
competitive there but you know at the
same time just because you're a
defensive coach don't just keep beating
your head against the wall going oh i
got to play through my defense no the
offense has got talent and you know you
you said it carry on johnson deandre
swift that should be a real damn good
combination
those two receivers along with tj
hawkinson who showed when he was healthy
last year that man he he's got superstar
talent so if they can get healthy and
stay on the same page there on the
offensive side of the ball i think they
can be dangerous it's just going to be
the big question to me is are there
enough difference makers on the
defensive side of the ball is there
enough guys do they have guys that can
make a play in a big moment or something
like that that to me is what i question
you know i know trey flowers is there
he's good player superstar no i'm not so
sure about that you know but who is it
who else is there on that side of the
ball that can make a big play in a big
moment or a big game and i guess that's
my biggest question about their team
here going forward well not darius slay
who they gave away for a third round
pick and a fifth round pick i mean you
consider what guys like jamal or jalen
ramsey and jamal adams have obtained in
trade value and you just wonder i mean
look they were at their wits end with
darius slay but um they got to replace
him and as you said before the draft
just taking jeff akuda
it's a wash it at very best if a kudo
works out as a rookie and does well as a
rookie it's a wash that doesn't make
your defense better right you're just
filling a gap that was created by the
decision to trade darius slice so look
they've got to deal with aaron rodgers
they've got to deal with the vikings
offense and uh the you know
what's the best case for the lions in
that division given that they have to
compete with minnesota and green bay you
know i would give the lions like you
know it's a tough division and then you
know even let's not forget the bears the
bears were just they were close as the
closest hell of the damn playoffs too
and i don't think that defense is going
anywhere and especially with the
addition of robert quinn but you know i
i'm gonna go on a limb here where like i
think this is the first time i'm saying
about this about some of these bottom
teams here i think the best case is is a
wild card i do i think just between the
desperation of the coaching staff and
the gm i think you're correct mike if
like this the year fizzles out this
could be it for matthew stafford detroit
they might just want to go you know
change from there which you know i don't
know if i agree with that i think he's a
really special talent but yeah i'm gonna
say borderline you know a playoff team
is best case like sneak into the wild
card
yeah i agree with that if they can make
that happen even then i think it's going
to take a lot of dominoes to fall the
right way for them
the worst case is another disaster and a
reset button and sheila ford hamp gets a
chance to hire a gm and hire a coach and
and we see if we can finally turn around
the detroit lions after all these years
and
and maybe maybe
sheila fordham is the is the answer i
mean maybe the break from
the past right when when william clay
ford passed the sense was that bill ford
jr would take over the team he got
shoved out
martha firestone ford took over and and
maybe now handing the baton to her
daughter that's going to be the key but
you know
this is one of the realities of family
ownership of a football team you start
passing the keys around from person to
person
you just have to hope that the keys land
in the hands of somebody who knows what
they're doing right and and and that's
the biggest glimmer of hope for the
lions that with a new controlling owner
that maybe just maybe there's going to
be that spark there's going to be that
fresh look that fresh take she's already
said she's going to be more involved the
balance is to not be so involved that
you're undermining your football people
right but maybe maybe
it's
they're another team i'll throw out
there like you've heard me say with the
bangles a lot in the off season and
everything like rebrand rebrand it's
time to rebrand you know this uniform
doesn't work let's get a new look in to
maybe get some success into the
organization i really and there's no
lions in detroit either so they need to
fix that too
there's no rams in los angeles either
well except in the zoo well i know but
they were they were they originally the
rams there in los angeles i don't know
don't change the subject we're talking
about the lions right now i'll get
together when we get there
they got a real feral rams problem in
cleveland where the rams first got
started well maybe there was back in the
day i don't know who knows maybe there
were rams i don't know all right uh i
look i i don't i don't know if the lions
need to be rebranded but i will agree
with you over the last 60 years the
current brand hasn't necessarily worked
right uh but all of a sudden that
brand's gonna look good if the players
in the uniform start playing better than
they have historically let's take a
break
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports